الصِّيصَانْ
الحُلْوِينْ
خَلْفَ المَامَا يَمْشُونَ مبتسمين
هي تُطْعِمُهُمْ
هي َتَسْقِيهِم
حَامِدِينَ نِعَمَ المَوْلَى شَاكِرِينْ
الصِّيصَانْ
الحُلْوِينْ
خَلْفَ المَامَا يَمْشُونَ مبتسمين
مبتسمين
هي تُطْعِمُهُمْ
هي َتَسْقِيهِم
حَامِدِينَ نِعَمَ المَوْلَى شَاكِرِينْ
هُمْ صِغَارْ
لَكِنْ شُطَّارْ
لِوَصَايَا مَامَا هُمْ دَوْمًا مستمعين
هُمْ طَائِعُونْ
وَمُأَدَّبُونْ
حِينَ تُنَادِي مَامَا يَأْتُوهَا فِي الحِينْ
الصِّيصَانْ
الحُلْوِينْ
خَلْفَ المَامَا يَمْشُونَ مبتسمين
هي تُطْعِمُهُمْ
هي َتَسْقِيهِم
حَامِدِينَ نِعَمَ المَوْلَى شَاكِرِينْ
يَلْعَبُونْ
وَيَمْرَحُونْ
طُولَ الْيَوْمِ فِي لَهْوٍ مُسْتَمْتِعِينْ
مَعَ الأَصْحَابْ
أوِ الأَلْعَابْ
يَقْضُونَ أَحْلَى أَوْقَاتٍ فَرِحِينْ
الصِّيصَانْ
الحُلْوِينْ
خَلْفَ المَامَا يَمْشُونَ مبتسمين
هي تُطْعِمُهُمْ
هي َتَسْقِيهِم
حَامِدِينَ نِعَمَ المَوْلَى شَاكِرِينْ